ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
vous lire le message qu'une jeune fille
devenue femme a récemment envoyé à son
ancienne camarade il y a des années de
cela j'ai subi de ta part harcèlement
humiliation et attouchement ces
agissements ont bousillé ma vie
d'enfants et d'adolescentes j'ai pu me
reconstruire et construire une famille
formidable mais jamais je n'oublierai
ces heures de souffrance et de détresse
j'ai pensé à une période dénoncer ses
agissements cela fait maintenant plus de
40 ans c'est loin mais indélébile
cette jeune fille c'était moi
et je ne crois pas être la seule sur ces
bancs à avoir été victime de harcèlement
un enfant sur quatre on est victime
combien parlent le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame intime tu enfouis parfois
toute une vie le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame qui porte mal son nom car
il ne s'arrête pas en vérité au mur de
l'école il continue après les cours au
foot ou à la danse il revient par
message ou sur les réseaux sociaux la
nuit il hante les rêves qui deviennent
des cauchemars il a le droit de citer
partout
c'est un drame qui se niche dans
l'anodin une violence qui ne réclame pas
de coup une blessure qui ne se part pas
de sang je voudrais vous lire aussi ces
mots d'enfants qu'il expriment si bien
le harcèlement c'est comme l'uranium ça
brûle de l'intérieur le harcèlement ça
commence par une étincelle ça finit par
un incendie maman ce n'est pas pour rire
que j'ai voulu mourir
j'aurais voulu lire enfin les mots de
tous ceux qui se sont donnés la mort
avant de parler qui avant de parler en
haut du crier dans leur tête mais le
silence les a emportés il n'est rien de
pire que de ne pas parler sauf peut-être
de parler et de ne pas être entendu
Nicolas comme dans d'autres a parlé n'a
pas été entendu en parlant de honte vous
avez mis les mots justes monsieur le
ministre sur la réaction indigne de
notre Académie je sais que vous avez à
coeur que cette réaction partout change
mais pouvez-vous nous dire concrètement
les actes que vous entendez mettre à ces
mots pour partout par tous les combattre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal min Istre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Virginie Lanaud
Marion 13 ans
et va elle 11 ans Dina 14 ans ambre 11
ans
Lucas 13 ans Thibault 10 ans Chanel 12
ans Marie 15 ans
l'Insee 13 ans Nicolas 15 ans c'est non
ce sont ceux d'enfants enlevés à leurs
parents
ce sont ceux d'élèves enlevé à leurs
enseignants ce sont ceux de jeunes
enlevés à leur pays par un fléau le
harcèlement scolaire
ce fléau il ne connaît pas de frontières
ce fléau il tue et quand il ne tue pas
par la mort il tue la confiance en soi
de jeunes qui ne demandent qu'à s'aimer
et à aimer les autres madame la députée
j'ai fait des manominations au ministère
de l'Éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire ma priorité absolue et je le
dis de manière très claire je ne
reculerai devant rien je ne reculerais
devant rien pour mieux prévenir je ne
reculerai devant rien pour que la peur
change de camp je ne reculerai devant
rien pour que la honte change de camp
nous avons d'ores et déjà commencé à
agir avec des décisions importantes qui
ont été prises cet été sur les sanctions
à l'endroit des harceleurs demain la
première ministre présentera et nous
serons à ses côtés le plan
interministériel de lutte contre le
harcèlement pour aller plus loin mieux
prévenir mieux détecter mieux réagir
nous sommes engagés sur ce sujet nous
avons appelé à un électrochoc et je
constate que l'électrochoc a commencé
oui la peur doit changer de camp oui
nous devons être plus efficaces dans la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
c'est ce que nous devons à tous les
élèves de France c'est ce que nous
devons à toutes les familles de France
c'est ce que nous devons à l'école de la
République et c'est ce que nous devons à
notre nation merci beaucoup monsieur
menest